It's beautiful, isn't it
Solo and the city have air memo Strange everyone is so beautiful
Me, I'm glad I was able to see this I'm glad I was able
to stand here even with fuel
Why didn't you tell me
If I had magical powers
I  But if I become a magician in the state of Princep and use magic on you,
flowers will bloom,
won't my magic disappear?
You can't exist
without it That means you can't lose your magical power, right? It
could be something
else, but
if I talk to you, I'm sure Shingetsu-chan wo
n't do it.
Come on,
tomorrow the cut world will be even more beautiful
Saying
goodbye The world that
Shinryoku-chan wished for is waiting for you  It's a heart, more
I've received it all the way well
Pooh, so I'll never forget it One car Ah,
quickly lose the key cm To the
world
[music]
yeah yeah
goonie
[music]
wh
Sealed c everywhere  Magical power,
magia, many powders
Let's magic of Princep on this earth
Crystal of human wisdom